hey guys it is the 8th of December my
name is Jess and I love this Christmas
party was last night so bear with me
that's two years first up a bully has
been rereleased for Android and iOS to
celebrate the game's 10th anniversary
the mobile version is developed by war
drum Studios who also worked with
original dev Rockstar Games on the
mobile releases of GTA chinatown wars
san andreas GTA 3 and Max Payne the
Google Play Store description reads a
bully anniversary edition includes
everything from the critically acclaimed
bully scholarship edition plus support
for high resolution displays enhanced
graphics improved lighting and textures
and controls redesigned for touch
gameplay all while adding multiplayer
with new friend challenges France
challenges our classroom themed arcade
style mini-games where you'll race to
dissect a frog in biology or solve word
problems in English among other things
usually we're pretty good at uncovering
subtle game reveals and not so much with
the last of his pots - it seemed just
like how none of us noticed when Naughty
Dog teased to the Last of Us in
uncharted 3 back in September the studio
partnered with poster and apparel
company mondo to create this poster to
celebrate outbreak day which is the
fictional day of the quarter SEP
infection from the game reached critical
mass the poster shows off Ellie's arm
with the same tattoo she's acquired by
the time the last of his part two takes
place as seen in the reveal trailer and
somehow none of us figured it out
another lastest news first game's
director Bruce Straley will not be
returning to direct the sequel finally
Nintendo of America president Reggie
fils-aime may appeared on The Tonight
Show with Jimmy Fallon to show off Super
Mario run while we knew that much was
happening what we didn't know was that
Nintendo would also be showcasing the
Nintendo switch and giving Fallon the
chance to play The Legend of Zelda
breath of the wild Mario creator Shigeru
Miyamoto was also in the audience you
can check out the full clip in a story
on games but on top of all that in
things that will make the west of
hangovers feel a little better
Miyamoto performed to the Super Mario
Brothers theme with the roots and it was
awesome so awesome I think we'll just
wrap this news episode with a musical
number and show
you solve it that's everything I've got
for you today do let me know what you
cared about in that comment box and I
will see you again tomorrow
I'm gonna lie down